wir sind unterwegs in der Provinz im
Nordosten Polens die Gemeinde kulesche
kostellne eine Hochburg der
Nationalkonservativen
Regierungspartei wir treffen Rentnerin
Alina eine der ganz treuen und
zufriedenen 8 Jahre peacereierung die
davor die hätten doch nichts für Leute
wie sie getan sagt
sie jetzt haben wir eine 13 und 14 Rente
es soll kostenlose Medikamente geben
echt viel für uns man hat sogar in den
Predigten vom Pfarrer gehört dass die
peace was
macht 8% wählten hier vor 4 Jahren die
peace wir wollen wissen mit welchen
Themen die peace die Wahl am Sonntag
hier wieder gewinnen
wird sie haben dieses Glaubensbekenntnis
Gott Ehre Vaterland wir sind Leute die
an Gott glauben und wir sollten für
diejenigen stimmen die auch zeigen dass
sie an Gott glauben ländlich abgelegen
konservativ nur Rechte Wahlplakate von
der Opposition finden wir keine das
peaceenarrativ und ihre Wahlspots
verfangen hier im Nordosten
1A Oppositionsführer Tusk der Erzfeind
in den peacepots er habe versucht Polen
zur Aufnahme illegaler Einwanderer zu
zwingen und würde es wiedertun heiß
es die als Hüterin gegen illegale
Migranten der Grenzzaun zu Belarus
Migration ein großes Thema im Wahlkampf
und ein Kinofilm der berühmten
polnischen Regisseurin agnerska Holland
darüber ist ins Visier der peace
geraten im Film Migranten aus Syrien auf
dem Weg in die EU via Belarus von
belarussischen Grenzbeamten brutal über
die Grenze zu Polen
gedrängt der Empfang ebenfalls brutal
pushbacks durch den polnischen
Grenzschutz
gleich drei Minister treten empört und
symbolisch am Grenzzaun
auf die Darstellung polnischer Soldaten
und Grenzschützer als Banditen und
Sadisten ist eine Praxis die von der
Propaganda von NAZ Deutschland und dem
stalinistischen Russland sehr gut
bekannt
ist wir treffen agka Holland bei der
Kinopremiere in Warschau für ihren Film
beim Festival in Venedig mit dem
Sonderpreis der jur
zu Hause von den
Nationalkonservativen zum wahlkampfa
gemacht es ist ekelhaft und auch
schädlich weil wer Wind ST bekommt
Gewitter und das Aufgreifen eines so
primitiven Nationalismus antideutsch und
antibrüssel führt nur dazu dass in
diesen Ländern der Nationalismus
WCH und wir werden am Ende alle dafür
zahlen setzt bewusst auf Polen
first ständig antitusk Spots und er
immer als Marionette von Berlin
dargestellt Reparationsforderungen
antideutsche Töne als peace
Wahlkampfstrategie Warschau die Willi
brandschule wir wollen wissen ob die
massive antideutsche retorik der peace
im Alltag verfängt wir haben hier eine
enge Beziehung
Florian Walz ist Deutschlehrer er lebt
seit 7 Jahren in Warschau spricht
polnisch und verfolgt die Politik in
Polen auch seine Schüler schicken ihm
die Wahlspots und
Mem ich nehme das wahr ich nehme auch
die die scharfen Töne wahr die von der
Politik kommen Richtung Richtung
Deutschland ich nehme das Wah was den
diese Kampagne nimmt man W nicht blind
aber schlägt sich jetzt nicht auf meinen
Alltag nieder auch seine Frau mon ist
Lehrerin an der deutschen Schule sie ist
Polin für beide steht fest es geht um
antideutsch auf politischer Ebene
Mobilmachung gegen einflussn aus Berlin
das ist natürlich gewollt also peace
will das so darstellen in der Hoffnung
dass sie einfach wahrscheinlich mehrere
wähle
erreichen was ich aber nicht vermute ich
glaube die polnische Gesellschaft hat
sich also ist sehr offen die Familie
lebt poglotten Warschau selbst auf dem
Land in ganz Polen sagen sie sei keine
Deutschfeindlichkeit zu spüren trotz der
scharfen
peaceetöne viele Polen fragen mich ob
ich schon mal irgendwie angepöbelt wurde
und machen sich dann sorgen dass das und
D sage ich nein Gott sei Dank nicht und
dann sagen sie
freuen sich dann dass es dass ich das
ver nein bei anderen Themen hat die
peace die Gesellschaft verändert allen
voran Frauenrechte in Schlesien stoßen
wir auf ein
antiabtreibungsplakat mit dem expliziten
Namen einer Ärztin die noch Abtreibungen
macht Ärztin am Pranger wir treffen dr
Gisela jagelska für prolif Aktivisten
ist sie zum Hassobjekt geworden in den
sozialen
Medien sie nennen mich Mörderin
beleidigen mich stellen Vergleiche mit
Hitler her und reden von einem
abtreibungsgeschäft dass wir dafür
angeblich bezahlt werden wir werden
dafür natürlich nicht extra
bezahlt auch das gab es schon zeigt sie
uns
Demos rund ums Krankenhaus mit Bildern
von Föten und
Dauerbeschallung seit die P das
Abtreibungsrecht verschärft hat ist
Abtreibung nur noch nach Vergewaltigung
oder Lebensgefahr für die Schwangere
erlaubt aber viele Ärzte sind selbst bei
legalen Fällen verunsichert aus Angst
vor Strafen und Gerede nach 8 Jahren
peace es kann noch schlimmer werden ja
wie in El Salvador also Gefängnisstrafen
oder wie auf Malta wo es ein komplettes
Abtreibungsverbot gibt aber im Großteil
Europas und auf der Welt gibt es solche
Vorschriften nicht und ich hoffe dass
ich die Richtung nach den Wahlen
ändert es ist eine Richtungswahl für
Polen wird es die peace noch einmal
schaffen in den Umfragen jedenfalls
liegt sie vorne doch das Rennen ist noch
offen es wird eine Frage der
Koalitionen in einem Land indem sich die
politischen Lager Spinne Feind
[Musik]
sind